das virus ist weiterhin in der gesamten
bevölkerung verbreitet und ich bitte sie
daher erneut eindringlich lassen sie uns
dem virus gemeinsam den wind aus den
segeln nehmen nur in einem wie in dem
wir unsere kontakte weiterhin auf das
allernötigste beschränken können wir
seine verbreitung verhindern
verreisen sie nicht treffen sie
möglichst nur wenige und wenn dann nur
dieselben menschen und treffen sie sich
möglichst draußen
bitte halten sie sich immer und überall
an die a + l regeln auch bei ihren
freunden und verwandten können sie sich
anstecken wenn sie erste anzeichen einer
erkältung spüren dann bleiben sie
mindestens fünf tage zu hause und wenn
wir die zeit des lok bei uns wirklich
achtsam nutzen dann bringen wir die
zahlen schneller runter und zwar sowohl
bei älteren als auch bei jüngeren
patienten wie gut wie diese pandemie
bewältigen das haben wir wie er selbst
in der hand das robert-koch-institut hat
vergangene woche acht einfache tipps für
die feiertage veröffentlicht diese gelte
natürlich auch für silvester und auch
für die zeit danach die acht tipps
können sie auf unserer website nachlesen
das virus ist weiterhin ganz deutschland
in allen bevölkerungs und altersgruppen
verbreitet und das wird auch noch viele
wochen lang so seien im krankenhaus
werden derzeit sehr viele unserer
mitmenschen aufgrund von kogit 19
behandelt auch sehr junge menschen
lieben in krankenhausbetten ganz
besonders betroffen ist aber die
altersgruppe der über 80 jährigen also
die menschen die ein sehr großes risiko
haben schwer zu erkranken oder sogar zu
versterben und natürlich leider sehen
wir auch nach wie vor ausbrüchen
altenpflegeheimen mit stand gestern
werden mehr als 5600 cupid 19 patienten
zudem intensivmedizinisch behandelt
das ist auch wieder ein trauriger
höchststand meine damen und herren
gleichzeitig sinken die freien
kapazitäten auf den intensivstationen
immer weiter aber nicht nur die
intensivbetten sind belegt sondern auch
die anderen betten werden rarer manche
kliniken fahren notprogramme damit sie
wenigstens alle akuten patienten und die
kurve 19 patienten behandeln können und
immer mehr ärzte und auch medizinisches
fachpersonal fallen selber auswegen
cupid 19
und ohne diese ärzte helfen uns
natürlich auch frei
nichts